Chị làm tắm về năm hành trình đọc lập tự gió hành phúc, là một trong những hạt động văn hã chính trị trọng điểm của năm.
Sự kiện không chỉ tá hiện chạm đường lịch sử và những thình yêu của đất nước, mà còn khi giấu tâm nhất của nhiều thế hệ nghệ sĩ và nhà quả lý, từ khâu chẳn bị đến sáng tạo các phẩm.
Ngay sau khi đẻ án được chính phủ phê dùi phê dùi, bán chỉ đạo và bán tổ chức đã được thành lập dưới sự trụ trí của tụt chính phủ phạm mình chính và phó thu tướng, mai văn chính.
Bộ phần hóa, thể thao và suy lịch là cơ quan thường trực với hợp với các bộ ngành diệ phương trịnh khai đồng bộ màu đàn tính độ và chất lượng tổn thẻ.
Trong kế hoạch đó, cuộc mý thoại nhất hành và trình lắm, đảm dận phai trọn đất bị thường trực, chữ tiếp thâm lưu và trịnh khai các phần việc truyền bôn.
Tự xây dự đáng, tiếp kế tổn thẻ, bố chỉ không dành trưng bày, chăng chỉ khánh kết, tổ chức lế khai mạng, nếm mạc, đến điều vố tính trị trụng của tàn bộ sự kiện.
Trong tối xa đại bữa là chắc dạc, bữa là bình dự, bây bày trò là đình vị thương trực mang tự trực,
cố phát way tối ra, kế mạc, tổn yên vực ní thật như bàn bây trịnh lắm.
Đừng thời phí vợ chắc chẽ bố ngành, biệt phương để đảm bà, kinh độ, chất lượng tổn thẻ.
Bục tiêu là mang đến một sự kiện tổn vọc, sương đáng, bây giờ mục tám năng cố khán,
phẩm nán khách gọt vừa lê văn lịch thật hả?
Để mào đầm chêu xong gẹ thật bộ văn hóa thẻ thào và dù lịch đã thành lập khối đồng nghệ thuật tình trọn tắc phẩm.
Khối đồng quy tụ, kế chương ra hàng đầu, lấy đậu cơ quan quản bi, và nghệ sĩ quy tính.
Lịch lượng nồng cót này, chữ trách nhiệm thầm định bào đầm trình mực nghệ thuật, giá trị thầm Mỹ và sự đa giản lội dung của các tắc phẩm trưng bày.
Quà nhiều vòng là biệt nghiêm tục khách quan khối đồng đã tình trọn má chấp tắc phẩm,
gồm một chăm năm vý tắc phẩm nhất anh và một chăm năm vý tắc phẩm Mỹ thuật tư biểu.
Tăng xong mỗi tắc phẩm là những câu chuyện là lắt cắt trên thực của lịch sử và lời sống,
văn hóa con người Việt Nam.
Trong số đó, nhiều tắc phẩm được các nghệ sĩ tên tội ở vụ sức dầu năm.
Những khối tượng bức tranh tắc phẩm điều khác,
và hiện hình tượng con người Việt Nam qua tưởng giai bản lịch sử,
đồng thời gửi gắm trong đó những suy tư khách vọng và niềm tím của người nghệ sĩ.
Chứ khuyện một đất tư gương nào cho đây, mình được thăm ra là càng của thị trường ngoài mấy mắn,
mặc cuộc đời, ở trong bình.
Lên này chế lắm, tành tiêu tháng mấy đam của đình luôn.
Nhất là này, mì thuật,
bởi vì sẽ mong ra người thuật về lắm,
kia tiến ra tiến mấy,
bởi vì tư khi vong ra, chong về,
về chiến lắm thăm của người nâng này,
về tành tiêu tháng, tành tiêu rân lực,
thông thời gửi gái tỏ tự con con trong tành tiêu,
và người thuật tiếp phy tỏ đây đây.
Bình tạng mấy thuật,
nhép anh cũng có phẩm tạo nên dựa ấn đất nét của chiến lắm,
anh sáng và quen khách, dựa thành chứng nhân cho lịch sử,
liều dự những kí yất cảm xúc và niềm tự hào rất tỏ,
có những buổi anh được gây lại mà cảm ổ lời gắn bó,
khách hỏa hình anh, những con người vùng đất đã trở thành nhiều tượng của tổ quốc,
tư chiến trường, bình cơm, bình đào, đến đây sống bình gì,
mà rầu sức xúc không nay.
Bỏ việc bao nhiêu như thế hình anh đã giữ lại được,
liều lại được để nó này đặc biệt,
tành giữ hình anh đừng là vả sảo như ngày thống nhất và dài phòng
tư phó hành ngắn bức hành về lại tự hộ mình ra,
trong xuất bà mình ăn ngắn tươi đã chục.
Và tươi để gián nông quân sách,
anh về lại tự hộ mình ra.
Cô dựa thăm ra,
một tự bộ hành về lại tự hộ mình ra,
một trở về tự hộ mình ra,
không những cô Việt Nam mật của thế giới.
Tại nhiên giá chỉ ảy đến với công chú một cách trọn vẹn,
ngày xong y hoàn tất tình trọn khô vận chuyển và chính bây giờ
được trình khai với yêu cầu chính xác tìm mi và ăn bản tệ đối,
tró tình tắc phẩm.
Tên bị vận chuyển trên nhật,
trên bị phương án tiếp nhận thương nhau đều phương,
sự dụng vận đều trên dụng đề bảo quản.
Nóng ngói, giữ người n giá chỉ nghệ thuật
và hỗ trợ tối ra cho công tắc chính bây.
Tụi đã về có các kế hoạch mi sốc sếp,
để có kế hoạch mi nhận tắc phạch ra,
để tắc tình.
Bộ ánh trời,
nên nhất và ăn phản nhất,
cho phá trình nhận hàng chúng tôi đã mua vùng tất,
tại rất liệu của người mào bản bống rón,
làm với nèo mà để cho các các tập được bến nơi trên lãng ăn bòa.
Và, tả mạng nhất.
Một đề mới đáng chuyển của trình lắm lắm này
là hoặc đậu giá thách phẩm biệt thuật,
so nhà đậu giá, trọn thực hiện,
cái thật với không ra trả nghiệp làm trình xin mai.
Hai hoặc đậu này không chỉ tăng tính tương tắc,
đứa ngệ thật đến gần hơn với công chúng
mà còn khẳng định giá trị kinh tế của Mỹ thuật Việt Nam,
giúp người xem hiểu và chính trọng hơn quy trình sáng tạo của nghệ sĩ.
Đâu giá không chỉ đến người thật đến gần hơn với công chúng,
và khách nhà sức tập mà còn khẳng định.
Giá trị quyết tế của Mỹ thuật Việt Nam,
trong ý đó không giá trả nghiệp xin mai,
tạo gưu vội để hình người xem trích tiếp cảm nhận quy trị sáng tạo.
Từ đó, hiểu và trên trọng hơn xa trị làm đậu này thật.
Trứng tôi, ký vọc, hai hoặc đậu này sẽ lần toàn tình yêu,
người thật của các phần của các phần của các phần của các phần của các phần của các phần.
Ý khô chỉ đạo tổ chức đến tưởng chi tết hậu trường,
cũng biết thật như anh và trị làm,
luôn rất là trỏ nhiều phối, vào đạo diễn độ và trịt lần chung.
Rửi sự chỉ đạo của tụt lớn, phó tụt lớn,
và sự phối học chặt trẻ của bộ bộ bộ băn hóa thiện tháo và rù lịch,
với các bộ này biểu phương.
Tất cả nước tới một sự kèm vất hóa thiếu biểu,
kì nềm tám nằm cua khánh bộ hai tình chiến,
qua đó lành trỏ giá trị đi thật,
nhất anh Việt Nam và quảng ba hình anh đất nước ra thử giới.